isaac tôt c'est comme identité acto dans
le langage espéranto veut dire le
contrat de l'identité
[Musique]
je suis hassan maad directeur général de
la société id acto iddac taux est une
société qui a été créée en 2019 juste
avant la période de la crise sanitaire
et qui est spécialisée dans le domaine
de la gestion des identités et des accès
on va dire les identifications des
personnes qui souhaitent utiliser des
services en ligne c'est une société qui
compte aujourd'hui trente personnes et
qui embauche énormément dans le domaine
de la cybersécurité alors le soft
content d'être dans un bassin de la
cybersécurité à saint quentin en
yvelines et c'est ce qui nous permet
aujourd'hui d'attirer des compétences de
toute la france
[Musique]
nous sommes spécialisés dans un domaine
de la cybersécurité qui est un peu
particulier puisqu'il s'agit
d'identifier les gens et de protéger d
usurpation d'identité sur l'usagé des
services en ligne nos solutions
permettent tout en assurant la sécurité
pour les utilisateurs et les
fournisseurs de services de mettre en
relation utilisateurs fournisseurs de
services et souvent c'est le rôle de
l'état c'est pour ça que nous
intervenons beaucoup dans de cadre de
projets étatiques et souverain
dès 2020 nous avons déjà réalisé un
chiffre d'affaires supérieur à 1 million
et puis nous avons doublé notre chiffre
d'affaires nous sommes à un rythme de
croissance de 100% ces perspectives sont
d'emmener notre technologie française en
dehors des frontières et donc nous
souhaitons aujourd'hui ouvrir énormément
de présence dans les pays européens mais
aussi sur le continent africain où la
demande actuellement est très forte
[Musique]